hello
Bob
yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo yo
can you hear me
I have this working today
oh kinda uh
old
bum bum
there we go
excuse me
what's up chat
[Music]
let's do it the thumbnail is gold thank
you
I think my character's in the spot where
I took the picture
yep we're over here now
uh they probably want to kill me yep
yep
hey the Cowboys did great last night
W's in the chat for that
well I wouldn't say they did great
I don't know about that
but uh they won the game so I'm cool
with it
let me get the heck out of here
I came here for a thumbnail and now I'm
stuck here where were we and what were
we doing
uh oh
I'm in trouble
Cowboys are football
yes
they are football
yeah I mean I wouldn't say it's a big
deal to beat the Titans you know what
I'm
saying
they should beat the Titans oh we have
to do Ronnie's questline to get via's
questline where were we on that
we have to get
a Finger Slayer blade that's what we
need to do but we have to go talk to
Ronnie
to be able to do so
so we have to go through the karian
manor that's right
got it
you made it to the mountaintops bro I
missed half dude we actually are kind of
killing it
it helps them stay in the wild card no I
know it's a big deal that they won the
game but it's not a big deal that they
beat the Titans
talking about hand egg football
wait how many of you guys are European
what's the build right now I'll show you
guys all my stats
check it out
here I'll get the [ __ ] out of the way
sorry uh
nope
good enough
it's a weird
build
mostly strength and decks
with random stuff like this would be a
build that you would be
you know
they would tell you to Respec
because it's so weird
yeah it's it's such a spread
Netherlands
Germany UK okay
a good mix YouTube tells me that uh 50
of my audiences from the US
and then the rest is pretty spread to
like a bunch of different places
good morning Celeste
X ass
it's ass
I like Texas certain parts of it
good morning Christian
Sweden so EU yep
yep yep yep
what'd I miss nothing we're just getting
started we have to finish Ronnie's
questline to be able to do fia's
questline to fight for the sacks
we have to beat Fortis ax millennia
Moog
um
Godfrey
eldenbeast
your hobby
I just showed my stats like a minute ago
I'm from caled so you're from Florida
got it oh fire giant right oh God
I don't want to talk about the fire
giant man
okay we also have
I think we can upgrade our Blasphemous
blade
but let's get through here first
let me tell you Ludwig Ludwig it is a
spread
it is a [ __ ] spread dude
like
it's mostly strength and Dex I mean I'll
show you I kind of block it but
it's a spread
ow
you're gonna get wrecked by the fire
Giant here's the thing chat
I'll be fine if I don't get hit
yep
now that's easier said than done
but that is the goal
foreign
that was kind of close
okay
I think we're slightly over leveled for
here right now
slightly over leveled
I don't even think we can
no we need forty thousand we're level
82.
not bad
is this weapon considered the Giga Chad
weapon
so Caleb is Florida Farah Missoula is
Oklahoma what other areas
I don't know
whatever the memes say
what's your favorite weapon ruins great
sword
we could go get that but
we can't really use it
God here we go
how are you so powerful I have a plus
nine Bloodhounds Fang that's how
look at that damage
whoa
mountain tops of the Giants should be
Alaska
crew
Altus is Europe
whatever you guys say
hi Kirby
Windmill Village is definitely
Mississippi
I've been to Mississippi
I can see that
all right let's talk to uh
the mommy
I'm over here in the snow fields
I'm sorry man well hounds Fang is
overrated I mean do you see me just
annihilating everything right now bro
why is everything American I don't know
someone said Europe
tarnished here
thou must have
some old this way
this way though I have no memory of
inconvenience Tommy Mommy okay dude
no reason in particular thou cleanest
intriguing
tree caps fate tests equip some spells
encounter I don't need them
will thou enter into my service
I am the witch Ronnie
I stole death long ago and search now no
sipping for the doll do you guys think
simping is bad mend the whole of it
and rid the world of all that came
before I think we did talk to her in a
church of Ella
I
see
not many would have accepted the offer
but I require as much for the most part
my command I anticipate good work from
me
like is it okay if you simp for your own
wife
or husband
good
I'm gonna skip all this
oh I can just go there I don't have to
meet everybody this time or wait do I ah
yes
I'm sure she makes you talk to everybody
or you can't get out of here
of course that's okay see that's what
I'm talking about
I don't know how you simp or someone you
don't know
I think that's kind of weird
which happens quite a bit
together I'll tell you whoever I marry
I'm gonna be a total simp for a complete
and total sin
I have to talk to blyde
ice yes go fish I don't know what since
we thanks for becoming a tarnish man I
appreciate it welcome
first member of the day let's go
I sent for you y'all don't know me
I could be a fake AI
just streaming For Your Entertainment
you never know
so all the Pokeman and Bella Delphine
followers are weird no all of her weird
simps are weird
I don't think there's anything wrong
with like following somebody and
watching their content but if you're
like obsessed with them like to a point
of where you would be considered a simp
time to get your priorities straight dog
because she don't know who you are ah
allow me to forewarn I shall send it
to Dale I look for okay let's go get it
we're already ready to go down there
we just gotta like
let's run it
following Bella is weird didn't she like
stop making content
I don't know I thought I saw a whole
YouTube video on your whole story so I
was curious
um and then she like kind of stopped I
have no idea
simping Ain't Easy
so you're saying simping is difficult
really
I agree grim
I agree
all right let's get the heck out of here
laughs
are we horny yet
um I think it's too early
too early to be horny
we did porn bids with her boyfriend
which killed her appeal with the simps
she started making porn
and that made it worse really
that's kind of weird what
all right interesting
if that's true like
they so you're saying they stopped
following her because they found out she
had a boyfriend that she slept with
who almost died
I prefer being a sugar tarnished
through Logan
I would be a sugar daddy
so fast you have no idea
I'd keep the house so clean
I'd keep the pipes clean if you know
what I'm saying
whatever whatever they need
I'm Yours
wake up
it was the not blithes dudes couldn't
see her as available anymore no the the
fact they thought she was available is
so odd ah there we go we got the statue
I must thank you mainly it was sugar
baby no I'd be a sugar
I would I would have a sugar mommy yeah
that's what I mean
at least for me I'd have a sugar mama
I would gladly do that
gotta keep that parasocial relationship
pure interesting we need a sexy emote
for are we horny yet that's a good idea
we need a lot more emote ideas
we have 18 more to fill
Queen
oh
okay
okay
and we're off
parasocial
yeah I would say it's probably at a
point in society
where it's a problem wouldn't you
and probably covid made it a lot worse
because everyone was stuck at home just
watching stuff online creating these
parasocial relationships because they
literally couldn't do anything else
I would say it's a pretty giant issue
that uh probably needs to be addressed
in some way
unfortunately if you want that title you
would be a sugar baby I'm I'll be
whatever sugar you want me to be baby
you know what I'm saying okay
that
I'll be whatever you want
Archies
I simply Jake
okay guys please I do not sim for me
okay
don't do it just don't send for me
all right
just kidding just kidding literally
don't Archies thank you for the two
bucks man I appreciate you man and
please don't SIM for me
unless I'm just kidding all right
let's see if I can do a level
flip that
I can't do a level
I'm going to live in your walls see
that's just odd
don't do that I have a pair of social
relationship with my husband Mom's cat
interesting
you telling us not to sip is gonna make
people want to sin for you more
reverse psychology
how did Vigor get to 25.
well I am wearing radagon Source seal
and we did get a few more levels in
bigger
you guys said I could wear it
so I'm gonna
so I'm gonna
I want Melina to ruin my life
guys
I'm gonna kill her
no stamina
okay
proof I have cams on Jake he didn't eat
a mango he is playing Elden ring he is a
YouTuber all of those things are true
so you must be spying on me
that's just confirmed
time for spins nope
we need 40 000 and we have 35 000.
hey how much money did Markiplier raise
for that charity when he released his
only fence
anyone still know
or anyone does anyone know
I'll probably make a video potato
I'm still debating on it
but I probably will
I have to go around that way right yeah
have I already been over here not really
a lot
a stupid amount I mean it's for a good
cause I think that's great
it took you two weeks to beat Melania
it's not bad a lot of people quit
and still haven't
Jake is interested in starting his own
only fans
did we make that a member goal
let's go
I'll declare this right now
I'll declare it
5 000 members
and I'll start in only fans
I'll do it
I'll probably make people
un
not renew foreign
if only stray won game of the year
if only man is the best cat game ever
made
but you don't have to clip it it's there
what's the catch 5 000 members
5 000 members dude we're at 230. that's
just never gonna happen
all right
let's flip this [ __ ]
you have fat [ __ ] okay my mom watches
the Stream
hopefully she's not watching right now
I haven't seen this cutscene in a while
makes four alt accounts
weird deformed PP
you'll never know
until then
we need to make a withdrawal here no you
don't
however I'm gonna I'm gonna point this
out to anyone who may be thinking of you
know helping out with that
with uh getting to 5 000 members for an
only fans
I'm going to Mexico in three months
and I'm gonna start working out like a
fiend
so just throwing that out there
like six days a week I think
I hate this guy
I've never killed him that early
I always have to fight him down there
that was cool
you're coming to my land I guess so
I stand
Jake trying to make a Sim I mean clearly
it works
ow
hey Saul
Stan even YouTube wants me to do an only
offense
that was a thing on Twitch too
[Music]
oh
I thought I died
why Mexico
uh we're going to a resort
so that's pretty cool
oh we can level
is there um
there's not a Grace down here is there
shoot
okay hopefully we don't die
oh
oh
oh
wait that's drunk stream isn't it
whenever it comes up on here I think
that's drunk stream
let's go
or it should be
Logan with the 20 gifted members thank
you bro
get some W's in the chat for Logan he's
been going absolutely freaking insane
the last few days and I appreciate you
man thank you thank you yeah please
adopt me
I think that's drunk stream or it should
be I think YouTube literally has to go
find 20 people to gift a membership to
if you don't have a membership right now
talk in the chat I think it'll give you
one
I think that's how it works and we do
get one
Grog stream let's go
are we gonna have to do that tomorrow
it's New Year's tomorrow y'all won't be
here
do I have any of these
oh see drunk stream yes sir Logan with
gifted 20 members
and then another two dollars I
appreciate it man God damn you're crazy
almost everyone in chat got a sub dude
for real
I don't know how YouTube works
YouTube is not giving me the option to
accept gifted memberships oh
that's so weird that you have to do that
like it's free money right
whatever
um
yeah go make sure you have that enabled
guys if you want a membership here
or else you won't be able to get one
that's crazy that's so weird it see it's
seeming to work now it's Gotta it
literally has to find people because we
don't have enough viewers
damn it all right everyone go text your
friends and tell them to come to the
Stream
Philip declares it
all right and now we gotta do a spinny
spin
but Logan
I really appreciate you man thank you
very much the gifted 20 but only four
people got it no it's slowly giving them
out to people that's how it works here
it's it's quite odd but see it's finding
people the more you talk in chat
the more it it it works
see
it's so strange I I really don't
understand YouTube but there it is
all right
everybody
like the thumbnail says
pray
for vigor
please
pray for it
because damn do we need it to beat Moog
Melania we really need it bad okay
okay now it's starting to work here we
go
please please please
it's not go to endurance
go
we have a weird amount of mind on this
build
at least we'll never run out man
actually that's good for Blasphemous
blade that's not the worst thing we
could have gotten
not the worst
let's go chat
if you got a gifted membership from
Logan make sure to say thank you hello
um Galactic narwhal just became a
tarnish thank you very much sir I
appreciate you as well
make sure to join our members only
Discord starting to grow a lot in there
so
go to the community Tab and make sure
you get a link to that
that's it top of the chat click the 20
gifted notification it's green on the
screen it'll take you to screen that'll
let you toggle the setting that's huge
information John thank you bro
I did not know that
yeah I didn't know that okay that's cool
it'll be at the top just click it if you
want to enable it and get a gifted
we want active people and not just sofa
viewers
you think that's what it is
I think you're right
when will you continue the magic build
whenever we don't have any other
incentives to do
I kind of like that for YouTube
I don't know it seems to be working so
whatever
you know what we need to do it's just
like in the game guys where it's like
you know how we complain and be like oh
man this kind of sucks or I died or
whatever
what what's the answer to that every
time
every time what's the answer
get good
so that means
we just need to get more viewers
you know what I mean
let's just get more viewers
it's a skill issue
just quit okay thanks man that's that's
good
all right it's starting to filter out
there we go hello
W's in the chat for Logan again
bye viewers I'm not a [ __ ] cheater
dude
a lot of streamers do that by the way
I will never do it ever
let's go is there no music for this guy
legit
you're tough
you're a big boy
this a big boy
okay I'm dead definitely yep there it is
there it is how was the Cowboys game
they won
they beat the Titans which is big
for wild card
spots but uh hello
it's not really a big deal to beat the
Titans
do you guys think there's a lore reason
why we can ride torrent on this Divine
bridge and no other Bridge
okay I just need to play better
right
bleed you [ __ ]
I was gonna say no way he jumps that
right
I'm using the game's mechanics to my
advantage
there we go
you know there are people on like Tick
Tock and Reddit that would call that
cheating
not crazy I'm just using the mechanics
bruh
bruh
yeah my thought that we can ride tauren
on here is because it's Ronnie's Bridge
it's just skill
need to set up a steam bot to nag people
to clicky likey
or we get to say it guys if you haven't
liked the stream yet go ahead and do it
it's literally the only way to get this
stream out to more people
like the stream every time you come into
the stream just like it right away
unless the stream's bad then don't
then dislike it I think that helps too
but make sure you like the Stream
because
it's a good stream
it's a good stream
Ronnie is Melina no I used to think that
and I don't think that anymore
like for days
bass streamer at least I gave you the
option
you know
where's the torrent lore
you guys want a torrent video
oh we hit 251 I just realized that okay
when will the drunk stream be
do you guys want that to be tomorrow
because it's New Year's tomorrow
so that seems like a good reason to get
drunk
but I feel like y'all won't be here
because it's New Year's
so maybe we do it when on a normal like
a regular day or whatever I don't know
um
don't think that'd be wise
what the [ __ ] is a drunk stream my
theory or my theory what we were gonna
do was
um
every death I take a shot but will have
a Max
that I can't go past
I get drunk very quickly chat because I
don't drink at all
I really don't
we're gonna have a max amount of shots
that I can take after the new year that
seems to be yeah I'm busy grilling
tomorrow I feel like
what do you guys do on the New Year's
Day
like January 1.
can we do it then
I don't know
please not tomorrow some of us have
lives
I did shots for subs and start and
people started gifting never ended
streams so fast to vomit in my life dude
yeah I can see that happening
do you drink beer no I don't drink at
all
like I I just don't I don't know why I
just don't drink very often I drink on
very special occasions but
maybe like a glass of whiskey maybe a
glass of wine and that's it
Maybe
January one okay we'll think about it
the next thing we need to decide is what
is the next goal and what is it
I think the next goal has to be 500
right
let me change this up we already hit the
goal
these guys are crazy
you inhale booze smoke weed nope I don't
do any drugs at all
I'm kind of lame aren't I
was gonna say like let's just make it
500 because we more than doubled it
before but we'll just double it here
and then uh I'm not making it five
thousand yet
should I just make it 5K
that'd be insane
why don't you drink alcohol
my reasoning for that is my dad warned
me
when I was younger like right before I
turned 18 my dad warned me and he said
your grandpa was an alcoholic because he
was a prisoner of war in World War II
and my dad had to deal with him drinking
his entire life
so
my dad warned me he said we have very
addictive personalities
and
he just recommended to me that I don't
drink too much
and I just I just didn't I listened to
that you know
because I agree we have very addictive
personalities to a lot of things
were perfectionist weird workahol like
workaholic type
people
and uh
yeah
so I thought that's really good I
thought it was really good advice
because of his experience with alcohol
his entire life so I just listened then
I was like that's a really good reason
to just
and it doesn't mean I don't drink at all
I just very rarely drink that's it
that's all
so I respected my dad's advice
I don't like not being controlled myself
so any drinking weed yeah I feel that
too
yeah W Dad yep
yep
Jake has more lore than torrent
oh I have so much lore chat I've had
such an interesting life
I was a pro golfer to any of you who
didn't know that before I started doing
this stuff
I was a firefighter I went to school for
firefighting and paramedics if you
didn't know that either uh
I was a pro golfer I played professional
golf in Florida
Arizona California
Texas a little bit
so yeah if you didn't know that stuff I
have a lot of lore
you just gotta ask instead of every
death take a shot make it every 10
deaths or some arbitrary number I don't
think I die that much to be honest
I might though because I'm drinking but
we'll see it we won't think too much
about it
I guess that prisoner of war thing
really affected your grandpa dude
uh well okay so he was in a Japanese
prison in the Philippines for the
entirety of World War II
think about that
as soon as he was deployed
they were captured right away and he was
in a Japanese prison cell in the
Philippines for four years
I think he was
22 22 to 26.
yeah baton Death March he was a part of
that yes he was
baton Death March
why was he in this prison it was World
War II
it they captured people and they yeah
how long did he how did he survive that
long
he did not talk about it until he was in
his 80s
so his entire life
um you know my grandma and he had four
kids with my grandma after he got back
um
he never talked about it
they would ask and he would never answer
until he got into his 80s and he started
opening up a little bit more about it
um they fed him like wet rice
he he said that he had to eat rats
from time to time
it's a really bad story
yes he was drafted yep
[Music]
um
I don't he was one of the very few
survivors
in the camp
and how you you guys know how they got
out
which I think is crazy
um one day
an American walked up to his cell and
opened it
and he said what happened
and the guy said War's over
and he got to go home
huh
it's a it's an insane story I've heard
horror stories your grandpa must have
been very strong he was a very good man
who turned to alcohol
um honestly
from what my dad like the way my dad put
it and how I feel about it I don't
[ __ ] blame the guy
you know
he was still a good person he just drank
a lot
you know that's it
this is how it is man
it it is a story that
could be a movie I think
because he
so when he finally opened up about it he
he said a big reason why he lived was
because of Smucker's jelly
do you guys know what that is it it's
lit I think it's the most popular jelly
brand I don't know
um
when he was in his 80s he wrote a letter
to Smucker's jelly
saying that when he was in the prison
cell in the Philippines
he
would think and imagine
mucker's jelly while he was eating
the things he had to eat right and he
said over time he could he could
remember the taste
and it would help him get through it so
he wrote them a letter
telling that story and they wrote back
and said that's one of the most you know
heartfelt stories we've ever heard
lifetime supply of Smucker's jelly to
him and his wife or my grandma
forever
Isn't that cool
anytime they want it they could they
could call up they gave him a number
they could call it up they could get
endless supply
that is so cool to me that they would do
that
and they were they were touched that
much from that story
so
it all could be a movie but honestly I
don't think you know he wanted to talk
about it that much
right so
yeah it's like a brain active thinking
of a way to survive and then sometimes
like this is another good advice from my
dad he said
think about what your grandpa went
through for four years
four and a half years something like
that
and
if he didn't survive
you wouldn't be alive
fill my respect for him went through the
roof
from that perspective right and you know
I didn't blame the guy for drinking a
little bit you know
it's like hey
it's all right
he was he was always a good person
is he still alive no he died in 2004 in
his
he was almost 90. so he he lived a long
life afterward
but he died when I was nine
very long time ago
that is a yeah it's a very long time
very long time
uh another thing he had to deal with
that he talked about a bit was
survivor's guilt
uh because he said a lot of people in
that camp did not live
so he he always wondered why he did
you know
like why did all those people die when
he he didn't
this is how it is I don't know how you
don't think about that when that happens
we we need a jake lore stream well that
that's like my that's my grandpa
it's my grandpa man
where did that story come from oh yeah
me saying why I don't drink very much
that's right
yeah his name was Arthur
he's a good guy I miss him
[Music]
Grandma's still alive though by the way
she's 98 years old
and doesn't remember a thing but she's
still my grandma
the W's for Grandma all right
all
right
um
where are we doing yeah we need to go to
FIA
because we got the thing we need now
survivor's guilt doesn't make sense
makes sense to me
watching everyone around you die
and you you don't that that would make
me sad that would feel weird
especially when you know all those
people
oh should I show the curse mark to Roger
I think Roger's already dead actually
um
you are 28 and -9 years so you put in 19
years age what
I'm confused
I can't imagine feeling guilty for
surviving no he doesn't feel guilty
about surviving he feels guilty that
he's one of the few people that lived
in all those people
it makes you wonder why you lived and
all those other people didn't
hmm
uh GB I don't know what you're talking
about dog
my mom has something similar she was
attacked when I was 10 and barely
survived and now she drinks
help with the memories of it
yeah I think it's just doing that
you know
drinking makes you forget stuff
it does
that's why they turn to it
the drunk stream doesn't feel right
anymore
uh did I ruin it damn
I I don't have a problem with drinking
chat
most of our grandpas are way cooler than
we'll ever be they were killed to
something greater and Rose to the
challenge I agree
I agree
[Music]
yeah let's do the curse marks I didn't
mean to bring down the vibe man maybe I
did why utmost
sorry with this
Godwin can take his
right damn it
yeah Peter our true champion sure and
though I can't be of any use to you can
I hold you tight
only for a moment
um
what up T free
we got a bigger hug
about a mild drinking run
hahaha
right
I was exactly play with Godwin
and it will surely stop well we're doing
this to beat fortisacs but we will have
the option for this ending
instead of the demigods as the Rune of
those who live in death
please
what I meant you had to be 19 when you
heard or notified about this
and take for yourself I mean that sounds
about right maybe 17 GB those who live
in death why would there be a specific
time that I was told any of this
because yeah because Grandpa didn't open
up about it
I think I was like Mike yeah Grandpa
opened up about it when I was 17.
and then my dad warned me about drinking
around then I would say that's right I
don't know why we're talking about that
but okay
this is gonna be a depressing video now
I'm gonna cut all this out guys I will
soon this is just for you
to conceive my
my brandish my rune
then take care of yourself
stay the persecution of those who live
in death by becoming I'm sorry I didn't
think it was that heavy man I really
didn't
well maybe it is
it I should have figured
sorry
great grandpa survived Pearl Harbor
don't know if he had Guild or not
I mean who knows
uh that's how many subscribers we have
Trey
it doesn't update for some reason
the subscriber count has always been
weird because we're at like
almost a hundred and
one
thousand
but it just says a hundred it's kind of
bad
um
okay is she asleep now do I have to hug
her again
a lot of hugging going on here
didn't mean it as a defense I I don't
think it was
what
this is goodbye my dear there we go but
I am satisfied I choose to lie with
Godwin of my own will
yeah remains of one chosen for me
definitely my child you know
my my dad and all of his siblings really
wished he opened up earlier on a
Deathbed
it took him his whole life to do that so
whatever it takes you know
at least he did a lot of people don't
you know
it could have been worse
[Music]
I wish via would drain me of my life
okay guys
okay guys
okay
how many runes do we have
is that enough for upgrading probably
let's I think we have upgrades for
Boston was played let's go check that
out
let's go check that out
I wish you could sleep with Fiat
are we playing cyberpunk or something
huh
what are to use my about to lay out your
own
X
oh we need a seven
what do I got that's pretty good like
we'll take that
uh
uh we haven't ate
we need a seven
nine seven and a nine that's not bad
okay potato
use the blessing oh yeah
good reminder good reminder
thank you
is there seven in Knox Stella where
where
where where where we already got the one
in volcano Manor
oh cyberpunk Elden ring does sound kind
of cool
through
nine and Caleb unless you yeah I already
got the one in caled I got the eight and
the nine and Caleb I'm trying to think
of where the other ones are
why'd you use the radiant one
I don't know
it because it doesn't it just doesn't
matter
Eldon room
okay
the riverbank
trying to remember where that is
this sounds like a normal playthrough
Captain not gonna lie
use the wiki I think we're good this
will be fine
I'm curious how it is against fortisac
you guys want the music up
here we go really [ __ ] loud by the
way
[Music]
all the way up
foreign
[Music]
that almost killed me
[Music]
excellent
[Music]
okay
I need to figure out how to use the
Blasphemous blade because I literally
went in there and went like this
okay
give me a minute we just wanted to
listen to the music again
[Music]
I might switch The Bloodhounds Fang too
because that that just makes this a lot
easier
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
he lifted it
[Music]
I'm dead
[Music]
dude the wings dude
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
that one hurt the soul a little bit
yeah did you guys see the osc vinyl
I'm definitely I'm going to order that
dang it dude that was so good
well at least we get to listen to it
again
can you go get er tree's favor for some
HP yes I already have that on Brendan
yeah I just want to play the yeah
thank you
[Music]
no
[Music]
what's he doing man
I can't see him
[Music]
close one
oh God
no
close one
I keep trying to like blind Dodge that
it's a bad idea
GG
oh God I'm dead
it almost killed me afterward I'm just
standing in the Mist
God I love that fight it's so good it's
so good I love vinyls yeah we have like
uh two record players here
yeah I have archery's favorite right
there
um
let's [ __ ] go now we got a lot of
spinny spins
a lot
let's grab that
in case we want to do the ending
you know what has better music
what game has better music
I have no idea
apparently God of War
right okay
where'd my window go I don't have my
wheel
okay there it is
okay bloodborne's music is really good I
will say that
okay all that chat we can level twice
good stuff
okay here we go
yep arc Arc decks here we go
of course it's not bigger but strength
is good
more strength equals more big Bonks
one more
is Arcane good for anything we have
[Applause]
there we go guys there it is good job
level 85 with this challenge though
pretty good
the blood dagger
I mean yeah we get better bleed that's
true
good point
okay so who who do we fight next
it is good for Bloodhounds Fang for the
bleed yeah
now the spinny spins do not want us to
uh have a good time they don't
who do we fight next
Moog
we could get the secret medallion
astel
yo let's fight [ __ ] next
yeah yeah
man that's a lot of work I think
is it
Ronnie will just be down under right
yeah yeah
zombies for blasphemous
I think we'll find them as we play
you're severely under leveled for Moog
you're mistaking me for a noob
does anyone here remember when I fought
Moog at level 30 on our randomizer run
where godric usually is
I beat him
I did
however he is scaled down so you're
probably right
top of the morning Trump
has anyone ever died the pinwheel ooh
let's go get uh this over here too I
just thought of that
okay Stan okay okay okay Stan
I like it
level 100 for Moog
and what do you guys think the levels
are for someone like
let's say level 100 for Moog and then
maybe like 120 for Millennia but you can
also just like get good
as well
your husband died the pinwheel once
you're married to that guy
I'm glad you got through that
just kidding
just kidding
you can get through anything if you get
through that
all right time to get knocked off and
die
49 of people who played Elden ring got
past Market
so you're telling me 49 50 of people
have not beaten Market 51 percent
great game
Jake have you played Singing Monsters
nope I don't know what that is
okay what do we want to duplicate
we have everyone we have Regal Lich
Dragon grafted full moon Blasphemous
what gives us the most runes
some people got bullied and left I am
kind of a bully aren't I
love him very much even though he died
to pinwheel okay well
good for you
I think Reichard gives us the most right
yeah
tell me
good stuff
good Chit Chat
did I not get my runes yes I did
well I died twice and never mind never
mind uh
let's get out of here
yeah yeah
whatever it is 50k is pretty good
I should know everything in this game by
this point
and I just don't
which is probably the reason I keep
playing it
oh [ __ ]
do you have any tattoos yeah
I have one on my back
I want to get more I want to have a left
arm sleeve
at some point
that's a good amount Esther
what's the white soup
so I first streamed the game on Twitch
by the way
somebody in my chat when we went through
here's I remember this specifically
they said
or someone said why is this water white
and somebody in the chat said it's
Godwin's come
and that's just what I think about every
time I go through here
every time
Elden ring tattoo I was gonna get
Melina's mark on on her eye right here
on my hand like right here
on my left hand
just go up the thumb a little bit
I think that'd be a good start to his
sleeve
very deep lore
but the like her eye Mark you know what
I'm talking about her that's who
I think that'd be cool to have on my
like
just right here
on my hand
god-free sleeve what the lion would be
sick
The Crow Foot yeah
fire Fist Ace I don't know what that is
so this is cool though
get Alexander on there
Bank of America tattoo
I definitely get America I kind of want
to make my whole arm like literally this
entire left arm
Elden ring bloodborne Dark Souls
I haven't fully committed to that but
it's on my head it's on my mind
that'd be really cool
get a fire giant tattoo
yeah I'll go ahead and put that inside
my butthole where he belongs
what's your Instagram it is in the
description
oh
the description I think it's AGT Shake
ADT Jake YT so like YouTube
we got a level let's spin it
spinning
wait I put it on screen right okay sick
that's kind of a [ __ ] waste dude
it's the lead like the least amount
we've gotten crazy
bro okay
let's continue
fire giant more like bad I like that
I like that
the whole chest face as a tattoo
fire giant will not be put on my body
get her doll I did
literally grabbed her [ __ ] doll dog
almost died
little little baby
he's a little baby
make your whole arm Omen tattoo
that's exactly what we needed wow see
what see what I said when like guys if
we just play we'll get it we don't have
to overthink it there it is you see how
easy life gets when you just don't
overthink it
look at that
look at that
one piece is incredible
I have not started one piece and I have
not planned to do so
I recently watched berserk
and it's one of my favorites of all time
that story is [ __ ] awesome
I wish they'd kind of do like a reboot
that isn't dog [ __ ] like I've seen on my
recommended recently
where it's like berserk 2016 and 2017
are the worst pieces of media of all
time
uh I saw that video and I was like yep
not watching that okay we have another
level folks
let's get it
got manga's incredible blob I don't read
manga I watch anime I'm not gonna read
the Manga I'm sure it is better
however here's what I did I didn't read
but I did watch a YouTube video a three
hour YouTube video
by the way three [ __ ] hours long
that read the Manga for me all right
didn't read the Manga but it explained
the entire thing to me
okay
all right spinny spin
dude when I announced that I watched
berserk people were like so you read it
and I said no I watched it and they got
so [ __ ] mad
we'll take a little endurance
endurance is never bad
never ever
all right
looking for Faith uh yeah for yeah
actually
I'm not angry I'm disappointed
uh that's okay you can be that
get better armor bro
where
who's armor
I'm throwing this on
am I gonna be able to make it through
the swamp
do you need to do we're going to astel
ass Jill
who is a remembrance
eight
20-hour vid watch it over a week you
don't need to read the thing yeah I got
the gists of the entire thing it's one
of the best stories I've ever seen
now I want them to make a good anime on
the entire thing
because I did watch the anime from like
1994 and I still enjoyed it a lot
but then everyone says like they left
out a whole bunch of stuff I'm like okay
I'm sure
so then I watched the manga video
and it was good
it was good
have fun in The Lakes
1 40 P anime I thought it was cute
like I enjoyed it
yep the I heard the 2016 berserk was
like just the worst thing ever
so I will not watch that
you could have stolen the tree Crucible
one in the deep root deaths you guys
gotta remember like I'm kind of limited
somewhat
um on what I can wear without fat
rolling okay so think about that
well I'll throw this on for you guys is
this good
you want me to wear this
we go full nine for you
um
there you go this is us now
batboy run
I feel like you would like full
Alchemist Brotherhood I have not seen
that I have heard really good things
about it though oh wait let me do
something I have an idea
how we can get through here easier
get more rot resist no I'm gonna not do
that and just heal through it like an
idiot okay ready uh
so there's half HP steadily restores HP
over time
big brain right here chat alright I
don't know if this is gonna work
but we're gonna find out
it probably won't
but we're gonna find out we're gonna
find out
this was not big brain enough
big brain and I'm not
this is not good
we're gonna have to go in a direct
straight line all the way there and heal
perfectly each time
I'm literally only looking at my health
bar
foreign
I'm a very silly boy
very silly
foreign
y'all said no you can't do it watch me
watch me
because I did it
I did it
there it is
I made it
no I haven't watched Wednesday yet
I haven't watched Wednesday yet
get bugged
foreign
good comment
I'm good Vance how are you
I'm gonna go over here
I mean suck my dick please
I bet you're good at it
okay here we go let's not get infected
odd to say
you guys think I'm a normal person or
something
where have you gotten this idea
okay I don't have like exactly what I
want here
let's go this way
a crown is warranted through running
past everything
yes
at this point in the game's lifespan
yes
no
thank God I had that on
oh
none of us here are through
foreign
did y'all see what I just did
no no
that that was some Pro rolling until I
turned into a [ __ ] Noob real quick
oh my God
that was so good until it wasn't
I saw you get shomped
uh-huh
I've never dodged that attack like that
like that was sick
see that right there is what usually
happens
yeah that scared me
that grab attack is literally scary
[Music]
bro
Pro Gamer
don't kill me
no I'm dead bro
I'm dead
[ __ ]
yo x to the C what's up man good to see
you thank you for the 10.
that's really that's really nice of you
thank you what's up dude
I remember that name
appreciate you appreciate you
I got stuck on this guy for two days
watch me beat him in three tries
Here Comes
it's gonna happen
X thank you man I appreciate it
foreign
dang it
I kind of thought that wouldn't hurt me
but it did
[Music]
good
so if I get hit by that I die by the way
if I get hit by that too I know
yep rolling rolling
no
no
man
my My rolls are so good
until
I'm trading in your Galaxy
okay
okay
I was reading text thought we
feel like I dodged a couple of really
spicy attacks
and then I died to like a dumb attack
jump attacks kill you oh [ __ ]
yeah maybe I shouldn't do jump attacks
like maybe I should just hit it
right
[Music]
foreign
excellent
if only I had some vigor
[Music]
you know
that'd be great God dang it
stop
what a weird attack
[Music]
you should bump your bigger
that's a great idea
[Music]
haven't heard that one before
oh
[Music]
there there was another meteor
see I thought it was over and it wasn't
there was another one
he got rocked
through
you should equip archery's favor
yeah you're right
another really good idea
foreign
nice
[Music]
[Music]
I just gotta not get hit you know
but that's how this works man
just don't [ __ ] up
okay I got hit
I got hit again
maybe I should take my own advice
have a good one cat
foreign
make sure to remind your husband that he
died the pinwheel
ever let him live that down
oh okay run under
roll roll roll roll
[Music]
chat uh the fact we die to that attack
in one hit is a problem
that is an issue
that's karma for clowning her husband
you're right
I'm so confident I'm not even gonna pick
up my rooms gets hit I'm gonna go pick
up my roots now wasn't that yesterday
okay I'm gonna wait to use my physic
until I see that attack
Fair
[Music]
that's not good either
oh that straight up kills me too okay
you know I only backed up like seven
times you know
uh still couldn't get out of range
physical type resistance
I want to go change my [ __ ] up but
there's no Grace down here and I'm too
lazy to come back
I'm god-free right
that's right
run instead
I mean I did that
twice
and I died
got a follow-up to that
look at that roll look at that Dodge
it's like every time I talk I die
no
I rolled it I am so good at this game
I [ __ ] rolled it
okay no grab that's that's cool
yep yep
okay good
Jacob Dean's
now you know my middle name
[Music]
that's okay
I'm like throwing
just beat him
you annoying [ __ ]
[Music]
can I get a stagger Maybe
I'm that good
it's really just that easy man
you just don't get hit by the boss and
then you win the fight it's just that
easy
it's it's very simple
foreign
GG good fight bye see you next time
that's another remembrance down
ready to go
ready to go okay
okey dokey
solid logic I think so too
now just don't get hit when it
why did you have to bum out my mood by
mentioning the fire Giant
all right
that's our next course of action isn't
it okay all right I you know
God damn it all right how many levels do
we got two what here we go
you what
okay we're this randomizer wanted a
strength build
it did it's what it wants all right keep
it going
all right more bleed it wants us to have
a Bloodhounds Fang build that's what it
wants that's what we're going for
definitely not any kind of vigor
that'd be nice uh
guess not though
all right
I'm sensitive about the giant I am I'm
sensitive it's a very sensitive topic
okay
is that where we're going are we going
to the fire Giant
hmm
it's time
it's time
Moog should be easy now
I don't know about that
but I appreciate the confidence
why would you need Vigor if you don't
get hit by the Giant
solid logic
um guys just like with the fire giant
let's not talk about Melania
what what do you guys think my
percentage is for beating millennia
foreign
like
four percent
I don't know why I'm doing that
yo it's Tom [ __ ]
no Vega just violence
through dude
thank you for the two dollars Tom it's
good to see you again how are you
appreciate it man just dual reduvia
no that sounds
bad
could I go get another great room like
should I go get more gots you think
I'm good Tom glad you're doing well
oh God God skin Duo
I just thought of that too I'm not as
scared of that fight now
as I once was
it boosts vigor that's why I think we
should go get it
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
where was the last checkpoint to that
wait
that guy just one shot me
I think I'm gonna go get more God's room
now it gives me more bigger I I think
that was just a sign that I need that
I find it so annoying that you have to
have a rune Arc enabled for your great
room to do anything
and remarks are not like that well I
guess you can buy them
I want to go grab the Rune but I can't
you know I gotta not die on the way
there
Vigor doesn't exist apparently not oh
[ __ ]
tarkov
I've been watching tarkov on Twitch a
little bit game's fun
I used to play it
once you activate it just don't die
you can summon let me solo here for
Melania
Lemmy solo has been in this chat room a
couple of times no cap
if he's here
let's go bro
I'll let you take care of her
I don't gotta worry
yeah he has been here a couple times
it's cool I kind of Fanboy a little bit
that's probably why it doesn't stick
around for very long
it's my fault all right I'm killing
these guys
daughter wouldn't let me watch miss a
lot dude your daughter should watch
just kidding
um
we just be [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
not so strong off your horse huh what
oh no
okay
I forgot about that guy
I'm come come
wait this one turns big right unless I
get it
I think this is a somber five
[ __ ] you Gideon
zombie six
don't need it but good to have she's two
months old yeah she should watch
unless I'm annoying and I like wake her
up I summoned let me solar before I knew
who he was during the fight with her he
got hit so I tried to take the aggro off
him and he left straight away that's
that's the
you can't do that man
here I'm gonna go down here chat because
that's a boss fight this way
I'm gonna hit this and then I'll go back
up
why Gideon because he's the [ __ ] that
put those bugs there have you not seen
my videos
use it to spy on you
yeah it's let me solo her so if you get
involved he leaves
we're going to the fire Giant
that's the next one
you know it's let me solo her
just cause he got hit doesn't mean he's
out
foreign
is this fight gonna be hard
Maybe
let her solo me better
who that guy is
see look isn't this weird that he's dead
in this place what is he holding
he's holding a Cho a torch
and a sword
okay here we go
he just glitched into an animation
he hit me what
never mind that was pretty easy
do a bit about this
I definitely haven't seen anybody talk
about this it's really weird
but then you come back
and the guard is back
he's over there
I'll even show it
he's out of render distance
all right no I'll show it when I come
back
or you can just [ __ ] believe me all
right
at least it you know I think it's a boss
fight where it's like hey if you beat
this boss we'll let you not run the
entirety of the bridge without torrent
by the way
what's spinny spiny at I think we can
love it once
I don't know Chad told me to change my
armor so I put on the most obnoxious
armor
we got one spinny spin let's go
please give me something that I can that
I can work with
it's not that it's not that
I mean maybe
[Applause]
that we can use uh
the Moonlight Greatsword do I have
enough for that
maybe if we finish Ronnie's whole deal
I don't know
I can definitely use some like spells
and [ __ ] I should use that
I mean this build is so weird
thank you
goes from looking like Giga Chad guts to
Pillsbury skin boy I mean I'll change
uh okay no hood
look is this better no
uh
yeah I like this armor I don't know why
someone gave me [ __ ] for that
oh that looks kind of clean
hmm
three stat 89 times no thanks
that Smoker's better
oh that's 38 inch yeah then we can't use
that
I kind of wish there was a photo mode I
mean I have a mod that does that but
yeah I wish there was in game
Bing Bing
all right
great rooms
good good good let's just see the
character's face right giga
yeah Armor's really not that big of a
deal it's just for looks it's kind of
like well bloodborne has like good stats
but it's kind of like bloodborne
I love bloodborne's armor system and its
Style
like for the for the clothes it's so
[ __ ] cool
do you plan on doing convergence mod for
Dark Souls 3 yeah if if we don't have
anything else going on we can absolutely
do that
also what are we doing for 500 members
guys what are we doing because this is
at 251 and we hit our goal again so now
you gotta do a drunk stream
which will be which will be fun it'll be
fun and then uh
yeah now we need 500.
naked stream
no
all right
no
oh is that Ronnie cosplay dude I feel
like that should be higher that should
be like a thousand
Ronnie cosplay is insane
and I would go hard at it too like I'd
go get like an outfit and [ __ ] and paint
my face blue and everything I'd go I'd
go crazy with that
Ronnie spells only
no
dagger only
a hitless run will literally take us
months of work
we could do it I guess
no cap
we mean like no hat I always wear a hat
Guitar Hero Run with the guitar
well I have a Guitar Hero guitar
it's not a bad idea
it might be just as hard as the hitless
Run
foreign
upgrade run
that'd be quite hard
imagine what Ronnie's forearm pits smell
like
I'm good on that fight by the way no
thanks I'm going up here
every soulsborne game with each spell
category
hmm
what would be a good
500 member stream
bat roll only
what about no rolling I just have to
Poise everything
so overloaded
randomize we already did a randomizer
are you gonna kill shibiri now I'll just
leave him alone
oh I could take his armor
through I might I'll kill him I'll kill
his ass [ __ ] him
is this game possible without torrent
you want me to uninstall the game no
so I can beat the game without torrent
it takes a long time there would be a
lot of downtime in that
let's just test it no no never mind
what's not
every enemy is Market
I have an idea
well didn't we have a double enemy
should 500 be the double enemy one
every there's just two of every enemy in
boss in the game
I'll do his uh dialogue
and then I'm gonna kill him
finally
we meet
the tarnished
who would be Lord I'm skipping there's a
thing I feared well as for you I hope
you can make your
about to sacrifice something precious
why Dark Souls 2 is the best game
all right press one in chat
double enemy run so every enemy and boss
in the game is there's two of them so
two Millennials press one in chat for
that or two whether she wishes it or not
we play Dark Souls 2.
we do a Dark Souls 2 playthrough
tread the path
spare the poor girl I do lore runs all
the time change your own flesh oh God we
need a pole
and detained lordship through righteous
hardship making up all the words of I
shabrieri
double enemy or DS2
playthrough
ass community
we're pulling it get your votes in now
get your votes in now chosen tarnish
then would be Lord descend into the
depths far below the Earth tree capital
see Gordon I wouldn't let you go through
the pain
get your votes in we're gonna go off
this chat
can be spared
righteous
of lordship the path of the Lord of
chaos I'll let that run for a while the
Earth tree
to the ground
and incinerate all that divides and
distinguishes
oh May chaos take the world
May chaos take the world
nice
[ __ ] you though
this I did not expect
Ed
guys it's literally split 50 50 almost
and there's 70 votes come on
everybody vote everybody like the stream
do all that [ __ ] it's 52 double enemy so
far I'm gonna let it run for a while
mate chaos
the world
and should I wear this
that's kind of badass nah
I'm letting that run for
maybe five to ten minutes
I always get a little hard when he says
that line right dude
yeah this arm is very drippy
whatever wins you'll do the other one
eventually right yes
I do plan on playing Dark Souls 2.
which ending is your favorite personally
it's Ronnie's ending like lore wise I
think it's
the best one
um but
the uh flame of frenzy ending is really
[ __ ] sick
I'd say Ronnie's though
uh is there more than just PVP stuff on
the member Discord oh yeah there's you
know a place where you can have like uh
you know it's a normal Discord as well
and we're adding stuff there
all the time
so it's definitely not done we I mean we
really just recently got
a good amount of members
we must make it a perfect 50 50. don't
do that vote for what you want
the Ronin armor set
who's the villain in this game Gideon
well
I'd say he's the most
villainous
yeah I have a suggestions channel in the
main Discord
so I could make one in there too
oh
okay there's another somber 8 just in
case we need that later I think we
already have one though
Gideon is a dick yo
it's kind of like owl
and sakiro true
all right it looks like double enemy
wins so we'll do that at 500.
I like Demon Souls I haven't finished
Demon Souls yet but I plan on playing it
this year
or this next year
nine coming up I think we already have
no we don't have a nine
somber smithing stones are dragon's
teeth
or they look like it
uh
uh well
large gold smithing Stone drained of
color
special armaments with unique
characteristics cannot be strengthened
with cut with colored smithing Stones
number of steps and amounts strength and
differ from the standard weapon strength
is plus six I mean it doesn't really say
does it maybe
the Remake Joe yeah
you have DS2 runs on YouTube I have I
have played Dark Souls 2 for a total of
four hours
I have never beaten the game so I don't
I don't have it on YouTube
I dislike it
that much
well we gotta kill
[ __ ] man
do we go to Castle soul
no
I have this [ __ ] ass Giant on the mine
right now this is gonna be a [ __ ]
oh my God I I am not looking forward to
the fire giant guys I am not looking
forward to it
but we gotta do it
oh the bloodborne d-make I haven't
played that yet I've heard it's really
cool though
I'm not fighting this dragon
nope
hit on next video topic
the next video I had planned is editing
down this entire stream series for this
Challenge and making that into a video
I think I am gonna do that
I consider it better than three not as
good as one I mean it's all opinion
based I love Dark Souls 3 because it was
my first Souls game
that'll always have a special place in
my heart
a lot of people aren't just what like a
lot of people probably just have me on
in the background GB
you know they're probably like cooking
cleaning
doing some like normal people [ __ ]
how many likes are we at though
y'all should like the stream if you
haven't already
nope not getting like
yeah a lot of people are playing Elden
ring
I have you on in the background while
I'm doing your mom
no you're not she's right there
I got you on my new 4K TV nice Flex by
the way real quick
16 likes
nah
we have 171 likes and 167 viewers
that means people left bro
couldn't be me bro couldn't be me
oh wait
imagine not being here the entire time
has anyone done this yet people said
that uh someone did someone said it
earlier I haven't seen it
but this challenge has been pretty fun
people are leaving
yeah that happens when you mention
viewer accounts they get all nervous
they're like oh
and they just did it
I don't know I never had my view count
on I was just going based on what Chad
said
imagine the rest of our roles are all
bigger
can you imagine
um
hi big hand
that'd be so nice
now it's not gonna happen but it would
be nice
what that's too many people I'm leaving
right
all right
a lot of you don't may not know this
about me but I don't like the fire giant
fight I consider it one of the worst
fights in the entire game although it
looks incredible
I think fighting the fire giant is just
the worst experience of all time
especially when you get them low Health
after 20 minutes of bucking his ankles
and then he just starts going ape [ __ ]
and I have low enough Health where I'm
literally going to get one shot by
everything
however I'm going to go into this
thinking that it's all my fault it's a
skill issue and I just need to get
better and it's not the fight itself
let's get it
mentality is everything chat
this is gonna be fine
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
of why I [ __ ] despise this boss
there it is
for it
if he gets
farted on
slightly touched by the fire Giant
he won't move or four to five seconds
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
I just I I just I you know
I thought I played that
perfectly
the fire is kind of coming out from
behind his feet
and it insta kills me
you said it me dying there had nothing
to do with my one greedy hit
it's that that [ __ ] fire hit box is
stupid
the angry this entire fight I'm sorry
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
s
thank you
wow
did I get hit was that a no hit fire
Giant
I have fought this boss so many times
and got and have gotten so angry that
I'm really good against him now
but I still hate him
exactly Joe you don't need Vigor if you
just don't get hit chat
hey
let's go
yep praise be to the bleed
hey
that's how you do it right there you
know what I'm saying that's how you do
it
let's do some spinny spins
and like the Stream
for the no hit fire Giant
that was kind of sick all right here we
go
I'm sorry about my anger with that boss
chat I just hate it I hate it more than
Melania
I I oh my gosh I hate it okay four
spinny spins let's go
boom
fire Giants way worse than godskin Duo
[Applause]
that hurt
that hurt my soul it did
what's new alright here we go
[Applause]
I don't need Vigor you're right
at this point I don't need it
I'm just getting trolled
it is what it is
okay hey
it trolled and then made up for it there
we go
there we go
one more one more okay
endurance I like it
honestly W roll
[Applause]
that was a good spinny spin
let's go
let's go
knee hill
oh we gotta be God skin Duo
last to do sex
malikath
I think we have to beat Godfrey
and then we fight Mogan Melania yeah
I think that's what we need to do
man
do you hate Melania
no I hate the waterfowl
but I don't hate Melania
all right let's watch a cool cutscene
burn our waifu
foreign
need of repair
and death
indiscriminate you thinking what I'm
thinking
to commit
a cardinal sin
well we get locked out of every other
ending
because I'm not gonna do the entire
questline of millicents to get to that
hmm
do you guys want flame of frenzy ending
or any other ending
don't Frenzy
Frenzy
um
we should spin the ending
um
we don't get locked out of flame of
frenzy right if we go through with this
like can I go get the flame of frenzy
after this
is that an option
I think we should spin the ending when
we get to it and if it is flame of
frenzy we can go get it
okay then let's do this very well let my
hand
that that
just to spin the ending I like that
man then I gotta go find [ __ ] gold
mask whatever hey if we get it we get it
we'll do it
yeah we've already been deep in the
sewers already like we we could go down
there and get it right now but we'll be
okay
we have the death Prince ending we did
fia's questline
I love this cutscene
it's so well done
how many likes we have print
199 or something
like the stream chat if you haven't
already like the Stream
it helps a lot
oh a tree you shall burn
do you hear the twinkling in the back
like from it like from Gwen
from Dark Souls 1. do you guys hear that
there's literally twinkling sound of
fire just like from Gwen bun
hear it
now it's gone no it's still there
yeah it's still there
not the music the sound effect
but guiding me here
[Music]
I wonder why she tried to reach out to
us
like what was she thinking
there
the one who walks alongside Flay
shall one day meet the road of destined
death
goodbye
bling bloom
I know the all the games are combined
has been pretty much debunked by a bunch
of people on Reddit
I'm still not fully convinced that the
games aren't connected
there's not a ton of evidence for it but
just that right there is so strange that
the sound effects and the music are very
similar to Gwen
very similar
Oklahoma
we made it
we made it all right keep it going keep
it going keep it rolling
they're set in the same universe just
different times
yeah
definitely if they are for sure
like if they if they are then yeah for
sure
why is Melina connected to Azula
I I have to think it's Destiny
we're destined to go release destined
death that's our fate
so we have to
oh it's Ohio sorry
yeah I have a Melina and Ronnie lore
video
they're pretty old now though
[Music]
some NPCs die
right
yeah if we want to do the gold mask
ending
or should we do like the big four
and not like the other ones that are
just kind of reskins I don't know
flame of frenzy is a big one Ronnie's a
big one the normal ending's a big one
uh
and then the rest are kind of like the
same right
so
much
that's just crazy
yo
all right [ __ ] it
I don't get that Grace
that's fine
uh oh that would have been bad
age of the dung
that's a seven right there God damn
God damn
all right what are the chances I beat
godskin Duo without a mimic first try
like I just run down there and [ __ ]
do it
I think I should use Blasphemous blade
for this fight right
I think Blasphemous blade would make
this fight easier
let's go see our upgrade options
you do not pass the Vigor check listen
you're talking to a guy who needs oh
Corn's already dead guys it's over uh
yep can't do that one I forgot you just
have to burn the air tree and he's like
[ __ ] I'm dead
whoops all right well that one's out
wait
oh yeah yeah
seven eight
and we just need runes for a nine
it's pretty good
we'll have a nine
we have a plus nine Blasphemous blade
and a plus nine Bloodhounds Fang
I don't know if we're gonna get much
better odds than this
wait where where do I go is it here yeah
it's about true death in Japanese sense
of true death is only achieved by Honor
could be about it could be about it
all
there
uh probably not I haven't talked to him
the entire time
okay
I think I should add
maybe a 6'4
for this
what we got rocking right now we got it
rocking and rolling
let's go give it a [ __ ] shot man
God I hate you
oh wait I'm dead okay we're fine
foreign
oh wait I have Blasphemous blade
okay
[Music]
why is this thing so weak
it doesn't do [ __ ] to him
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
put them to sleep says every person ever
during this fight
okay we're not using that that was ass
oh my God these like these movements by
these Knights I don't I can never figure
it out man
it works I know I just find it extremely
boring because it's all I ever see
born man born
but it does work
you're right
nope
nope nope nope
that wasn't very good
yeah I know about the easier run back I
just saw the door and I went in because
I wanted to
yeah what ounce finesse seems like it
should have iframes
but it doesn't
oh boy
let's go this way it's Diamond Bernal
is he even gonna be there
I don't remember where this Secret Door
is
or how to get there I don't remember
oh it really was at the other industry
man oh
boy
well we'll try that on the next attempt
[Music]
Bernal is pretty good
foreign
[Music]
nice 98 runes
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
dude why do we got a bunch of like back
seaters in chat all of a sudden
let me play my game dog
okay
I'm gonna do it my way not your way I'm
sorry
that's how it'd be
yeah Vigor would really come in handy it
really would
it's not over here is it I just don't I
can never remember where this is I'm
sorry
oh that's Bernal
God damn
best way to fight the duo is to not get
hit by the boss
you're right
I'll remember that
foreign
well I know this isn't the entrance that
you all are thinking of but [ __ ] it we
have Bruno let's go
[Music]
let me move what the [ __ ]
foreign
keep them over there Bernal hold on
but I might get lucky with the bleed
there probably bad I thought
I
god dude
I hit roll and it just
didn't happen man
it just didn't happen I think I held the
roll you guys ever hold the roll
and then
because you can't hold it and then wait
to press
I did that there and it wasn't a good
time to do it
I'm playing listen I'm gonna do it with
this weapon
I and I'm not gonna listen to advice I'm
sorry I'm just not going to
I apologize for this is Bernal gonna
fight these guys if I go in here
let me see
he does come in here okay that's good we
learned
he will follow you in that's that's good
because I'm scared that he's just gonna
bite the people outside okay yep that's
why I died there not because I got
[ __ ] farmed or anything but you know
you know
you know how it is
if you don't hit you they don't die see
this is the advice I want
thank you
[Music]
come on Bernal
oh
I couldn't see what he was doing man
[ __ ]
[Music]
run
all right I'm inside him
well that sucked
do the pillars not stop his ball anymore
they never did that's not true
I've definitely got him stuck there
before
foreign
what
bernal's a legend
damn well that's bad
yeah they're both Gonna Come Back
oh he's gone
yes he has to snap him back
nice
that was so big
jump in the air don't do ball [ __ ] you
no
stop oh my God bro
this [ __ ] ball
God damn dude
oh
God he just doesn't stop rolling it's so
annoying
it goes on for way too long
in my opinion man holy [ __ ] it goes on
for way too long
ah
that hurt the soul too
foreign
[Music]
nice Rune Arc I like [ __ ] man I thought
he would be he's like all the way off in
Narnia the other one so I'm assuming
he's fighting Bernal and he just Chucks
one at me uh off screen cool God damn it
dude
why is my luck so bad man holy crap
we've got enough levels in Arcane that's
not luck that's discovery
I just got did so [ __ ] dirty
whatever
it just adds another like level of
uh
stress when you pop a rune Arc
okay
[Music]
where's Bernal
where is he
where'd he go
all right
I forgot how frustrating the end game is
for this game and especially when you
have no [ __ ] Vigor it is uh quite
difficult as well
and then there's this guy
I don't this is already an easy run back
though I'm gonna keep doing this one
also bernal's here so I think I think
it's fine
I guess I get hit by that guy but God
damn
oh boy
[Music]
hey no I summoned him I I even went over
to the yes and it just didn't work
twice
if you do it too fast does it not work
just died the same way two times
excellent
excellent
[Music]
oh my God I don't like the swipe
I don't like the fire giant either but I
I don't like this fight God
level 94.
but why does the summon not work
you have to wait to summon before you go
through the fog
I do summon them though
okay
and no this will work
I guess I didn't get summoning
cooperator before
there
[Music]
pin
thank you
hmm
I'm having a good time
why does this oh my God
sorry I had to get some anger out
I had to yell I'm man
the end game is
hmm
maybe level up a bit
read the title I didn't summon them
[Music]
well
[ __ ] it
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
getting annoyed by a lot of things right
now
and I'm gonna calm down
I'm just gonna calm down
okay
good
good
okay
focus on you
do something that I can actually hit you
foreign
that's a three piece
let's roll too [ __ ] early man there's
no other way to put it
foreign
I don't know how that first hit attack
hit me I have no idea how
[Music]
okay
Ronaldo's beat the other one
stuck on what and why are you up
you all stuck on to where you're not
even
um
stuck on that little [ __ ] dick post
oh my God
dude I'm getting so [ __ ] frustrated
holy [ __ ]
oh my God and then he just does the
weird belly flop thing that's like
basically impossible to dodge
with with the fire along with it oh my
god dude
who thought of this fight
God damn man really
[ __ ] dude
like give me a [ __ ] break
why are they both so aggro
I guess I didn't do it again I don't
know whatever
[Music]
see he did get stuck until I moved to
the side
[Music]
whatever
oh my god dude I'm getting
um
at least the music's good
yeah
no I I mean this fight is
like
I feel like they're trying to do
Ornstein and smoke again
and they failed so hard it's funny
[Music]
all right well I was inside a [ __ ]
like the camera was inside the wall
there so that's great in inside the
pillar I think that's just unlucky
if you were trying orange seen in Smoke
they would make Nobles slower right yeah
my point on that is that Ornstein and
smog is the best design Duo boss ever
and this is the worst
[Music]
he's trying to sneak up on me
well he's definitely fighting uh the
knights unfortunately
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know if I've ever seen him do a
tail swipe
uh oh there's the dick again
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
keep going Vernal
[Music]
nice Bernal
foreign
use the other side of Grace
it has no enemies
I'm going to [ __ ] poop my pants and
send it to you
how about you sit back and watch instead
instead of typing comments you're better
at that
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I swear to God he delayed up there he
waited a little bit longer he did I saw
it
I beat
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
get over here
those nights are still fighting how
thank you get over here man
God damn it
[ __ ] this boss dude
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
stay over here
[Music]
still get one shot by like literally
anything
foreign
oh my God
thank you Jesus
the only good thing about that fight
and press one in chat if if you agree
with me
the only good thing about that fight
is when it's over
let's do some spinny spins
and calm down a little bit because God
damn
we got two spinny spins
let's do it
yeah and the music's good but you know
we let's do it four other times
throughout the game so
spray all right already a strength build
I can deal with it
I can deal with it
go go go go go go go go
like it what it's so close to the bigger
look at this look at that it's so close
but it's not there
it's so close
Michael
thank you for the super sticker that
says cool
I appreciate it man thank you very much
I like that one
all right I guess you know hey guys you
know who needs Vigor right who needs it
I'm starting to lose my mind if you
can't tell
who needs Vigor just don't get hit by
the boss right
just go get hit forehead that's all it
takes
ow
ow
could use some bigger there
[Laughter]
just level Arcane in mind the newest
rank well yeah I guess so but you know
bigger is quite important in this game
if you didn't know
it's very important
[Music]
my forehead hurts
wow
why is there a hole there
do I have another Talisman slot
no how do I get the fourth one I don't
remember
where do I get that from
don't want to get it from India in the
in the round table
yeah that Talisman is huge we are
definitely going to use it
gravity outplays vigor
yo true
it's trying to get to another side of
Grace
you buy it from the Round Table
okay but we'll go there
Kelly and Ronaldo we killed Ronaldo
Ronaldo dead as hail
I'm not fighting that Crucible night
I'll tell you what now right now
I'm the greatest swordsman in Elder ring
wow that's really cool
okay let's go from here to the Round
Table
yeah we already got those chat we I
think we get it from Enya the one we
need
um she might be dead
no she's still alive
give me my pouch
what do I gotta do to get it from her
dude
I think it's too late actually
foreign
why do I get two of those right there
does she have two storm Hawk axes she
does that's right okay
uh bill
offerable
uh uh there it is
let's go
why are we still using this
raises it
does that help us in any way shape or
form
no
all right whatever
man
really not doing ourselves any favors
but let's go
all right
chat
class to do sacks
or malacath
I forget which one I go to
yeah it's the rooftop it's all the way
over to the side
that chick with the staff was hot beep
uh I don't know about that one
ow
[Music]
do a poll
yo this might be the hardest part of the
game right here I'm not gonna lie
I should probably just kill the birds
place a dude's sack
Lassie first you'll need the extra
levels for malakath I think that's the
play
I'm gonna try running one more time
[Music]
this is going well
get up you [ __ ] okay
no
just keep healing
[Music]
I don't get it please
really
dude the damage output
in the end game is so inconsistent like
sometimes it'll be like oh that'll hit
me for half my health and sometimes
it'll just [ __ ] destroy me out of
nowhere
[Music]
I can tell this Terror guy is just not
the guy we want in chat
I can just tell bro
bye bye
you got me in a bad way right now dog
I'm the best swordsman in all of Elden
ring
did a woman beat up godric
this bad timing to be an idiot okay
all right oh oh yeah all right yep okay
[Music]
I love this game it's a good game
I wish I had some bigger that'd be cool
foreign
kill the birds
bird down
see what a little bit of breathing does
[Music]
foreign
okay
wait there's another [ __ ] bird here
[Music]
dog
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[ __ ] that
[ __ ] that
I know it's a plus 10.
we'll come back when we get to it
get me to the [ __ ] elevator now
thank you
we made it
okay
let's go kill plassy do Saxy
I am like
this playthrough maybe it's just the you
know the build
the situation the challenge whatever
but this air this this is making me hate
Fair Missoula
like I [ __ ] hate it dude I am having
such a bad time in pharah Missoula
class to do sexy
together
I know you can do this I died so many
times here but I know you're better than
half the players of this game the pickle
believes in you we all do
thank you pickle
I appreciate you man
I can do it
you're right
I'm skipping it
we want the music anyway let's go
guys for me this is a music all the way
up in no talking fight
here we go pickle thank you again man I
do appreciate that we got this
I am going to get frustrated though and
I think that's fine
blasphemous ly good here
foreign
too slow
all right so we are literally just
getting one shot by everything at this
point in the game that's what's
happening that's all that's happening we
are getting one shot by everything that
touches Us in the game even the Birds
were basically taking more than half our
health
so here we go
I personally use Blasphemous play but
that's just me
do you think it's better than
bloodhound's Fame
why did yuble get banned
because I didn't like him that's why
no I'm not using rivers of blood
let's try it
see how it is
let the know hit run begin that's pretty
much what we're gonna have to do potato
thank you for the two bucks man thank
you
I really don't need any other reason to
ban somebody other than I don't like
them
I'm euble are you [ __ ] stupid goodbye
this is I knew it was some dumbass all
right whatever I knew it was the same
guy because nobody knows who Yubel is
except me
[Music]
who has two YouTube accounts
I guess I have two YouTube channels
whatever
I feel like that was decent damage for
the one I got
worst run back it is an optional uh
you know
secret boss
guys who get banned frequently have more
than one interesting
interesting
oh yeah that's kind of weird
thanks Jake
oh I know I can do this I just can't get
hit by anything
if I get hit chat I die that's how this
fight is gonna go
I think Blasphemous bloodhound's Fang is
gonna be better for us Chad
just simply for the fact that we can
bleed plastic do sex
I'm not going to use Bloodhound step I'm
not a [ __ ]
foreign
I ran out of stamina
I tried to roll and I ran out of stamina
man holy [ __ ]
foreign
[Music]
yo Peter
let's go man thank you thank you for
gifting five members
I appreciate that get some W's in the
chat for Peter
thank you bro
thank you thank you
yeah I think Bloodhounds Fang is going
to be is gonna be it
but thank you Peter
I needed a little okay
I can do this
I really hate that yeah this run back is
really bad because we're gonna just
attempt it over and over and over again
but
you know it's one of those fights
especially when you have low Vigor that
you want to get back into right away
just happy to be here you rock thanks
man I'm glad you like it and I
appreciate the support a lot
I've died here before so I'm like kind
of scared
of this jump
ragging with Greece
I don't think anything like that is
gonna make a significant difference
I don't think there are any tips that we
can really have here guys
it's literally don't get hit
that's it
we have a very strong weapon
you know we're as good as we can be
considering the challenge
get good and don't get hit that's it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I didn't remember that one
[Music]
[Applause]
dude the fire Lings for so long with
basically every dragon fight in this
game holy [ __ ]
it's just there for so long
okay I mean that was better right
dude I'm so impatient I just want to get
back there
guys like I I don't understand the hey
use this or use that
if I get hit I die no matter what we're
using
it's not gonna help just stop
I know they're just trying to help but
they're not and we've said that many a
Time
that's all
why is Fair Missoula such a spike in
difficulty I mean it is the end game for
an open world game so I mean they ramped
up the difficulty by a lot compared to
the rest of the game but God damn
[Music]
hello
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
more Peter's gift that are coming in
I don't know why I just like stared at
his [ __ ] head or his uh
his hand there and I'm like I'm like too
far away like I'm usually way closer
than that
and I'm like right up on it or too far
away like just further away than I
usually am and I'm just like I don't
really know what to do here
that was like a spacing issue for me
this in the Haley tree are the worst
yeah honestly like getting to Millennia
is going to be difficult
no
we did not do nihil I'd say we go all
the way to beating Godfrey and then we
do Melania and Vogue
you know
use the force you should
guys what are the chances that somi is
also youble
and I should just ban him right away
he was annoying yo
like 10 minutes ago you [ __ ] idiot
is my first rodeo
[Music]
[Music]
all right
I guess
wait that reaches right here what
[Music]
at least I didn't die
[Music]
foreign
I don't know what else to do there
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
that's good
[Music]
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
dude
is that hitting me
I I literally don't get it and now I'm
dead
makes no sense what the [ __ ] man
I I'll probably make it into a video
Trey the end game's killing me here bro
it's [ __ ] killing me dude this this
has ramped up to a completely new level
okay I'm just Banning this guy because
that's clearly the same thing I feel
like I'd have an easier time with
malacath I'm not lying Chet this is so
hard it's kind of kind of crazy
I might try malacheth for a minute here
like there's barely any Windows to hit
placidusacks where there are a good
amount of Windows to hit malachath
armor doesn't do that much in this game
man
foreign
a little bit but it's not going to do
that much
like my bigger solo I'm I'm just gonna
get one shot
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know why some of these attacks
are hitting me
that was my fault
it's a thousand times more aggressive
yeah he is but I I know the move set I
would say I don't really know
placidusax's moveset that well
you don't want to use the easier out but
you don't want to get one-shotted so
just get a better weapon I
what
this is one of the best weapons in the
game it is
it does a ton of ton of damage
like we're fine I just have to not get
hit I don't know why this is so hard for
people to like register in their head
while I'm while I'm doing this
come on thank you
okay
I also know this weapon really well too
the end game is Just
frustrating me I mean this is really
[ __ ] hard
take only has skill the boss before
dying
right
[Music]
one hit
yikes
wow
thanks for the super sticker man
five dollars super sticker it's a cute
little jumpy uh controller that's cute
thank you
thank you very much
youble uh you need to get help
stop making so many accounts it's weird
we don't want you here and I don't like
you go somewhere else it's a better use
of your time
and have a great day
I don't know how to make that more clear
trip thank you again man appreciate you
phase one is tough I I can figure it out
here though
don't know how to make that one more
clear chat
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
remind me to turn down the music
a bit unlucky there
it is what it is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that's pretty good
that was pretty good
David thank you for the five dollar
Super Chat came for your channel because
of the lore but this no hit run is quite
fun that's not what we're doing but uh
I'm glad you think so David thank you
man thank you thank you
it's not your favorite fight fear
I like the malachath fight it's it's fun
it's it's fun to learn
really hard though
basically looking for one attack to
dodge or I'm looking for one attack
which is my opening to hit him in this
fight
for you ball okay okay
what are you talking about GB
thank you
I'm so dumb that was not what we were
looking for by the way
this one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
music oh my God it's so [ __ ] good
I'm keeping the music loud because that
was actually a really good
uh attempt there
I forgot about that attack to be honest
pickle Rick
if he keeps killing you I will find a
way to into the game and repeatedly kill
him for the glory of the Wind with no
one messes with tarnished especially
ones with maidens and the pickle Rick
who got this thank you pickle
we got this let's [ __ ] do it
for you bull
y oh [ __ ]
thank you pickle
oh yes
harassment uh that's okay
we just keep Banning them
bad attempt bad attempt that didn't
count that one was for you bull uh this
one's for pickle
thanks Stark
wait did the tree sandal respond or did
I never see him
I mean I never killed him so yeah
why are you not wearing a helmet because
my face is giga
I think it's funny
oh God here he comes
sometimes he comes right at you bro
[Music]
so unlucky when he does that
let's just do it again you know [ __ ] it
[Music]
three times
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
let's [ __ ] go boys
foreign
I think I held roll again man [ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
I feel it I feel it bro
RTS thanks for becoming a member bro
welcome back I think it says renewed so
thank you
good to have you appreciate it
chat make sure to like the stream
because I'm definitely gonna kill
malachath really soon
why do people in my chat keep talking
about Andrew Tate
it's weird
I'm an elder ring streamer
[Music]
[Music]
all right that was weird
sounds
thank you Brent seven seven seven seven
seven
appreciate it man thank you
[Music]
unlucky
done by me
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
thank you again man I appreciate you
Stevie
welcome
oh you came at Elmore that's a big one
thank you very much
I appreciate the the membership welcome
uh everyone who's a new member today
make sure you go to the community tab
and go to the um you can get access to
the members only Discord I want to get
more people in there so make sure you do
that and thank you again let's go
[ __ ] got this let's go
foreign
get [ __ ] dude
God
I'm not gonna lie
alive
him doing that follow-up attack is just
awful RNG that's it
that's literally it
if he does another attack we're okay it
it's RNG for him to do like certain
attacks it's just so hard to dodge some
of them
that was not the same mistake as the
last one
thanks again Stevie and Brent seven
seven power of seven
I'm Gonna Save my flask for stage two
[Music]
won't be a huge difference but could be
good
why are you so aggro this time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
thank you Trey
I agree
let's go come on let's go let's go
almost same
[Music]
[Music]
this is insanely unlucky what's
happening
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I thought I was outside of the swing
[ __ ]
I thought I was outside of the Swing man
dude this fight is so
so awkward the fight is awkward and it's
hard
great if they keep going just ban them
like if they don't get a hint off of a
a timeout or us telling them to shut up
because no one cares
then we don't want them here
it's not even worth it David
okay fair enough Trey I like warnings
too
foreign
I can go for one hit and that is it
confirmed
foreign
felt like two
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that was kind of weird
let's hope we don't get hit
it's about the switch
[Music]
good [ __ ]
come
on
man bro
the these attacks are just so [ __ ]
awkward to dodge they're so hard
I mean also doesn't help if I get hit
I'm dead
that don't help
yeah I know Benny that's easier said
than done to actually do in the moment
sometimes you'll do a different attack
and then you don't want to be in that
spot it's just an extremely hard fight
you can't make a mistake especially with
no help
I just need to stop doing that
I just need to stop doing that
or rather do twin Millennia than
malacheth in some ways same
yeah British it I I know what to do in
this fight I know this fight
in and out
sometimes you can't do that and
sometimes like
if I'm too close I get stuck on his leg
die from that
even if you do go behind him sometimes
the AOE hits you anyway
I know everything about the fight guys
you don't have to tell me what to do
it's me doing it that is the issue
takes practice and time
[Music]
okay
all right
[Music]
both of those felt weird and unlucky but
all right
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
it's this bad RNG I don't think I've
ever seen him do that attack that early
ever
damn
I feel like I got his first phase down
pretty good
phases honestly give me the good attacks
or I'm probably gonna die man
it's a part of the fight Trek
Blasphemous Claw is not helpful
damn it
it's okay but
too hard to use it's not worth
one attack man you can't get two
I could do two there man it feels so
much like I can but I can't
foreign
[Music]
unfortunately
foreign
what the [ __ ] I have streamer mode on
why am I getting alerts
here's a picture of my dog to make you
feel better thank you potato your dog is
very cute
[Music]
ah he like delayed it a little bit man
[ __ ]
yeah I I have to only hit him once
I don't think I can do Bloodhound step
or uh Bloodhounds finesse I don't think
I can do it it just puts me in an
animation that takes too long
so
regular hits hope for enough hits in a
row to get a bleed off I think yeah
just wait for the good attacks to do it
if I do it that way
I just shouldn't get hit the entire
fight
take our time big big time taking our
time
[Music]
that was a little risky
see
no greed in this fight at all not
allowed
[Music]
foreign
it's just like if you aren't on it a
hundred percent I mean all I did there
chat was [ __ ] up my role by like not
even half a second and I died
that's it
I don't I think I got hit once in the
first phase because I kind of [ __ ]
around but I had first space phase like
basically completely mastered second
phase is like oh my God
it's so hard
dark stop being an NPC
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
but I guess I didn't
[Music]
all right
yes
really hard to master most people just
win without knowing what happened
honestly true in second phase yeah I I
guess I just [ __ ] up there I don't
really know what happened
two times I thought I hit roll and my
character just didn't roll and I
definitely had stamina
though I I don't know
I don't know
my game's crashing
it's crashing
it's like you're taking too long
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow that one is so fast I don't think I
can dodge it
my game is struggling right now I don't
know what's going on
foreign
[Music]
game
please
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
my God
dang it
that was the one dude
he he's just so [ __ ] nuts
the anime Kitty strikes again
Stevie
foreign
foreign
now I'm being stupid
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that one made no sense to me
[Music]
I can't believe that hit me I felt like
I dodged that but I guess I didn't
no if I take a break it's like
restarting until I have to keep going
foreign
it's like so impatient I want to get the
stage two so bad
[Music]
like do more damage [ __ ] it
[Music]
and Delane is Rock slings now
okay
it's so bad
[Music]
[Music]
all right okay
I wasn't getting hit by that attack for
like
ever and now I just died to it twice
in a row
I don't know what's going on with that I
think I'm rolling slightly too early
maybe
if it is it's
so slight it's kind of insane that it
matters
you guys said Blasphemous blade would be
bad against him right
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so much lag
dude come on
God
my game
is
dying
foreign
I'm telling you guys he's like doing
weird delays now
I mean I've been doing this fight for a
while like I can see the [ __ ] delays
that are just like added on it's like
comes out of nowhere
foreign
I'm definitely not goable
oh ban him yeah you're right it is
Yu-Gi-Oh
just ban him I can tell it's him too
[Music]
foreign
dude I'm behind the [ __ ] pillar
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and I still got hit what the [ __ ]
I literally saw my character halfway
through a roll and I still got I
whatever man oh my God he also did a
completely different start than he
usually does what is happening
I'm not restarting
hi Samuel
hope you're having a good day Samuel
or I'm pressing roll I don't know I so
on my screen I see my character rolling
foreign
it's like the boss fight is getting
randomized with its delayed attacks and
what it does
I feel like we played this game so much
that we're realizing all the little
gimmicks they put into the game it's
starting to become apparent like it's
weird
I brought that up months ago too
months and months and months ago of the
uh where the bosses go [ __ ] batshit
insane
when they get low health
like they just Spam every attack they
have
without any of the
the time in between that they should
have
guys I'm not taking a break do not tell
me to do that
very quick way to just piss me off
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what the [ __ ] man
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
to us
yeah man dude it's just [ __ ]
relentlessly unforgiving
this Relentless unforgiving fight
it hurts more and more every time
come on
[Music]
[Music]
just did that attack
[Music]
what the dude
it's like my role this doesn't matter
[Music]
foreign
sometimes that's it
foreign
X is fine
[Music]
I can never get behind him there dude
what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yes God damn it
just give it to me man like [ __ ] I did
so many clutch Dodges there too and it
just didn't
why am I not getting a bleed that's a
great question where is it I'm hitting
this guy like all the time
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
some of these hits just they hit
sometimes and other times they [ __ ]
don't
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I guess I was five off of when I thought
he would transition
that many times off
he staggered me back into it when I
tried to run away there's nothing I can
do
[Music]
this is just [ __ ] insane
I got a little impatient on that run
there anyway
I just want to go to stage two I don't
want to do stage one anymore like I know
I can do stage one without getting hit
it just takes so long just put me in
stage two
man
[Music]
I'm honestly at like [ __ ] it I'll take
some hits
don't care
[Music]
no
God [ __ ] you dude
it's hate how long it takes bro
what
wooden Rivers we got her I don't know
like I'm not gonna go and get all the
smithing Stones Saunders required to go
get it
no I'm not doing that
is he really resistant to bleed I feel
like I've knocked him before but maybe I
don't know
foreign
[Music]
yeah I don't know I'm I'm starting to
lose my mind right now Chad
I'm not going to use light roll
lead's not the way apparently man
Blasphemous blade has got to be too
[ __ ] slow
what
happened
yeah dude oh
[Music]
foreign
I just like my brain is in stage two
that's where that's why I'm dying in
stage one
all right
nice delay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
device Jim
in
[Music]
Tony man this my character just goes
like and and just doesn't [ __ ] touch
it's crazy this doesn't do it
I know I'm pressing the damn button
and then
you support ordering online or at phone
ordering what
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that one came in fast
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
yes
yes
just [ __ ] awful RNG
just [ __ ] swung man kept going
[ __ ]
so good
I mean I was fighting him perfectly
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
why does he do that
like the delays are so weird
[Music]
waited too long
again
hello
hi
it's Joy
it's your little butt hello
okay bye
[Music]
Joy came to say good luck
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[ __ ] awful RNG like just give me some
good RNG please just give me a phase two
Malachi that doesn't
do this [ __ ]
I dodged that [ __ ] attack man I did
the AOE just lingers on and it's just
insta kills me
damn
every death and stage two is so
demoralizing right now
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is going on dude
[ __ ]
oh God
just so many attacks
wrong weapon for him
you should be able to use any weapon
against any boss or any enemy in the
game and have it be fine
it definitely has to do with the fact
that we have levels and a bunch of [ __ ]
that we don't want
and basically a mistake means death
come up
[ __ ] you GB for real
what a dumb comment
[Music]
s
you're better than that dumbass comment
you're so much better than that dumbass
comment bro
God damn
I don't have mimics here
I don't want to use it either
foreign
yeah yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I don't think I've ever seen that combo
I mean he just went
berserk right there
he just went from one jump to the next
variation of the jump
to the next jump and then chase me down
as I'm running away from all of it
wow
and then from the one jump heated
himself all the way over to me to do an
AOE attack
going in the direction that I'm running
but yeah that has to do with the weapon
I'm using Chad right
[Music]
foreign
I keep mistaking that attack for the
other one I don't know why
foreign
I saw that movement and I immediately
knew that combo
really
you just must be an absolute Elden ring
God then
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
why did that happen
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
of test and death
to kill what
did the Stagger come from
where did it come from
through two hours of attempts that's the
only stagger we got
where did it come from
has remedy
good stuff
thank you x to the Sea
I appreciate that man
20 super chats a lot I appreciate it I'm
sorry I'm completely out of I am out of
energy completely Unbound it's all gone
I'm sorry I really do appreciate that
though oh my God
yes in the back end
I don't get it
let's go stack it but let's go you think
it's a bug
really
you think it's a bug
that doesn't feel good if it is it is
thin
thank you
boom baby drinks on me Austin with the
10. thank you very much I'm really sorry
guys I'm totally out of energy
it's all out of me right now I I
appreciate the super chats thank you
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm not gonna lie to you guys I almost
turned off the chat
laughs
I almost exited it out because I'm like
dude how are we not understanding not
everyone but some people
how are we not understanding that
Like You Gotta Know Me by this point
I'm doing it this way I'm not gonna
change it let me bash my head against
the wall it's what I do every time
I don't I don't get it man just
just let me do it and it'll happen
and I wouldn't get mad at you if you
didn't keep telling me what to do I
don't know 21 can you do something for
me
do something for me is that a song I
feel like that's a song Thank You Kelly
I appreciate that
oh
geez guys damn America has high hopes
for us struggle on young tarnished
tarnish
thank you Captain
[Music]
oh I think it was a bug you didn't get a
stagger before I know that's what I'm
thinking I don't know if it was a bug
y'all said it was skill uh I don't know
about that because
you know
it just randomly [ __ ] happened
out of nowhere did you see my reaction
when it happened I was just like what
like why did that happen I just want to
know what was the difference
did I hit him
a little bit more in the first phase
this first phase count the second phase
I think it does
for like procs on physical and bleeding
[ __ ]
this stream guys you are the best
I wouldn't say it's crazy but I
appreciate that you think so triff
well thank you triff thank you Angel
Captain thank you very much Kelly Austin
foreign
thank you guys you're being very kind
and I was not
so I'm sorry if I got a little irritated
there but man like maybe I should tell
you guys this stuff and get more
parasocial than we already are
I would highly advise and not tell me
what to do
until you're all trying to help
and I try to like dumb that not dumb
that down but uh tell you like hey maybe
don't do that as nice as I can as many
times as I can
and then when it keeps going and I keep
dying dude I'm gonna [ __ ] break and
I'm gonna get mean okay
I'm gonna break I'm gonna get mean but
dude
take the hint you know what I'd rather
you guys do
stay low Jake bad LOL
malakith over Jake
you can troll the [ __ ] out of me in
those moments but when you're saying
like you're not gonna beat him with this
you should use this go use this get this
item uh blah blah blah blah
that's a different kind of like get me
out of here type of type of vibe okay
it's already a very frustrating fight
it's like I got it you you guys saw me
do first phase without getting hit like
multiple times so I I don't know
so yeah I'm sorry if I got a little mean
there I think that's all I can [ __ ]
do today Chad I am so tired
oh
remember the orphan of cos fight Jake is
like this
I asked yesterday if you wanted advice
and you said yes
where
where
did I say that we do have to spin the
wheel it's been so long I forgot what we
were doing
and yeah orphan A Cause right
how long did that take me five hours
five hours to be orphan of a cause
banging my head against the wall Jake go
get these items Jake upgrade this go do
that get this no
I didn't do it beat my head against wall
for five hours
okay what do we got four spinny spins I
am so tired
imagine we get a bunch of viggers
imagine
that'd be cool
that'd be pretty great
gonna lie
oh well that's not bigger okay
long
[Applause]
okay
strength
good
good
not as good
[Music]
[Applause]
last one
not vigor
[Laughter]
no bigger guys uh yep what's new right
okay
oh my God I'm just gonna delete this
hold on okay
you know here
Now give me a second not even one Vigor
nope
hey level 100
look at that
look at that level 100.
yep totally easy mode
your build sucks thanks man
[Music]
foreign
here we go
I got an email
ah good excellent
we are level 100 with 21 vigor
that's uh
not ideal
at all
debating on keeping keep going or or
come back tomorrow man
oh my God
I mean I gotta take a break I have to
I have to
oh man
I mean we could finish tomorrow well
probably not I would say we'll probably
spend an entire day alone on Mogan
Melania
after this
I'm pretty sure
yeah we beat malekith I don't know how
many tries it was like a couple hours
man
one try on Gideon yeah should I try and
cheese them
like get them while he's uh
not doing that thing
where am I
okay
[Music]
can I even cheese them with this oh
[Music]
[Applause]
it was only an hour
it felt like two
that's not bad
yo Peter
thank you man
thanks for gifting five dude I
appreciate that thank you very much
that's very kind of you
thank you thank you
Madness grab
well I could use it
much less than orphan man
I must have been on one for the orphan
dude
hello
but Peter that's that's very kind of you
if you got a gifted from Peter make sure
to say thank you
thank you Peter
three days above the goal yeah man let's
go
oh what up Slugger I see you Lord
continue to struggle
no no no no no no please please please
being here today
I did too fast please
[Music]
become a lord
not even you
a man
cannot
oh God
easy stuff
he died
[Laughter]
so I know I can do that to Gideon
because I like to use the ruins great
sword chat
uh I just do that to him over and over
again
he just falls down
it's the way like if you want to be
buffed Gideon that's how you just Spam
him with that
do I have levels again
we got two levels let's do spinny spins
oh I lost my window
is it there okay we're good okay two
spinny spins Bang
worst boss in the game
we got yeah this this is good I'm fine
with faith
that's good
that's good
it's not bigger of course it's not but
uh it's not bigger again endurance
bucket why not man
[Applause]
faith is good at this point yeah all
right guys Joy's barking her head off I
haven't seen her very much today I'm
gonna go hang out with joy and we will
come back tomorrow okay
um
yep
what a day
what a couple of days we are on a
streaming grind right now but uh I hope
you guys are enjoying it seems like you
are but tater
good job today Jake Whoever thought of
this challenge is an idiot
here's to the next bosses thank you
potato I I just saw that I'm sorry I I
actually missed it and I'm an idiot I'm
so sorry
thank you I appreciate that very much
thank you all for all the
crazy amount of memberships we've gotten
over the last few days crazy amount of
super chats support I really appreciate
it man
uh thank you so
we'll be back tomorrow at some point uh
we won't do the drunk stream until we
complete this challenge
uh which I think Mogan Melania is going
to take an entire day of itself
probably probably and then I if I had to
guess like probably two more streams of
this and then and then we can do drunk
stream so
have a great rest of your day thank you
all very much again
uh if you're a new member make sure to
join the members only Discord it's on
the community tab go to the community
tab like the Stream
I'd appreciate it if you did and we'll
be back tomorrow for more of this all
right
have a good one guys
and I'll see you then
peace and love